hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
mitigating risks and optimizing security
of supply and diagnostics
i am jen woods of lab roots and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by saitiva
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their site at citiva.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
broadcast
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located in the far left of your screen
i'd like to now
introduce our presenter david raw
supplier risk management leader
saitiva for a complete biography on our
presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
david you may now begin your
presentation
thanks jen and welcome everybody to this
presentation
uh mitigating risks and optimizing the
security of supply
in diagnostics i'll jump right in and
take a look at the the agenda the themes
that we're going to
be exploring in this presentation so
first of all we're going to take a look
at
the importance and impact of security of
supply
we like to take a data driven approach
at sativa i'm going to talk about that a
little bit
and then how we look at mitigating
supply risks
particularly during unprecedented events
and then what products and workflow
decisions customers can make
to reduce supply risks and then finally
we'll wrap up with a quick look
at industry trends
so here is a synopsis of the
presentation if you like
how a day-to-day approach supports the
development and implement
implementation of measures to maintain
supply levels
even in uncertain times and as i said
we'll be taking a look at some of the
workflow considerations that
can help customers reduce supply risk
so if we look at the diagnostics market
the sales of
ibd products used in point of
care and clinical lab testing is for
forecast to increase close to four
percent a year
and then by the end of 2021
be a a market that globally is north of
72
billion together with an aging
population and
those kind of trends with rising disease
levels
and heightened demand for detection and
diagnostic solutions
in response to the coronavirus pandemics
these things will all contribute to to
that growth and in
in in addition to that medical providers
uh are increasingly relying on
relying on point of care and clinical
lab tests for early detection
to facilitate um then delivering
appropriate therapies
so in in recent
unprecedented events we have faced
uh inside teva in our diagnostics
business
a number of challenges and those
challenges
sort of paramount among those has been
production capacity
uncertainties around the supply of
critical raw materials
logistics routes and pricing
and at the same time customer demand
increased
tremendously for some of our products
and at the same time as that
forecast accuracy reduced so as a result
of this
capacity requirements were difficult to
plan
and then on the next slide we see
how we describe what we view as an
increasingly
complex supply chain environment
but the sativa security of supply has
long been an intrinsic part of our
culture and our business and our way of
thinking
and we strive to take a win-to-wing
cross-functional approach
in an attempt to secure the supply chain
and involve stakeholders from across our
business
a number of ways we do this first of all
we
aim to standardize our work to make sure
that things are
repeatable and dependable in our
processes and that we have
clear roles and responsibilities and it
when it comes to analyzing risk
we strive to take a data-driven approach
and this enables us to look more
objectively
at how we prioritize risk mitigations
and supply risk management
and in addition to that material
consistency
is needed because biological processes
often have narrow tolerance windows so
in that regard
we're very dependent upon our suppliers
so this slide uh depicts uh what we see
as a complex
supply ecosystem related to our ceramic
uh production and as you can see uh at
the top we have
a number of raw materials some of which
are off the shelf simple raw materials
others are more complex and
can be made to order by our suppliers
we have some of each of those that are
single sources
and some that are multiple where we have
multiple suppliers
so these uh this raw material um
ecosystem
is uh complicated and depends uh
requires
different types of material management
to secure supply so the raw materials
are
are taken in uh sub-assemblies are
or semi-finished goods are produced
and then the semi-finished goods are
bottled and packaged and then
distributed
to our customers and all the while this
is going on we we
recognize that we need to minimize the
change control burden on our customers
we need
reliable and consistent supply we need
as as low as feasible risk
and a high degree of transparency to our
customers and from our suppliers
and and consistent product
now one of the foundations
of our security supply supply program
is our supplier qualification process
and we have rigid purchasing controls
measures in place so the first stage on
this slide over to the left
is our supplier evaluation process
okay so the first thing we do and this
is a um
a process that's uh undertaken by
sourcing
is uh supplier selection okay
so that at that point we look at the
feasibility of a particular supplier
being able to produce the product
consistency into the capacity that we
need
before taking considerations any further
and at this point
we might select uh more than one
supplier for
for evaluation the next
part of the process is supply category
categorization and this is undertaken by
our supplier
quality engineering team and they
evaluate suppliers based on the types of
components that they're going to produce
for us
and
produce a risk delineation
between the raw materials and based on
that
supply categorization then the type of
supply
qualification process
uh is decided and then in the in the
uh the middle section the wheel if you
like
that's a um a graphic that shows how we
continuously
monitor the performance and re-evaluate
our supplier performance so it starts
with performance monitoring
on occasion in instances of poor
performance we
issue a corrective action report but we
also continue to monitor
suppliers qms status we have a
a rigid and very demanding change
control
process in place and then of course it's
uh
it's fair to say that none of this would
really work without the collaboration
of our suppliers so
uh just on the right hand side just want
to summarize that you know
our suppliers are required to have a
quality management system
in place but we also place requirements
on our suppliers
in terms of what the standards they
should achieve
in terms of integrity business
continuity management and recovery
and supply capacity and capability
and we audit our suppliers on a risk
from a risk-based perspective
regularly
so in the next section i want to take a
look at how we use a data-driven
approach
to work with supplier risk management
so first of all we have an in-house
developed
tool called the sourcing risk finder
tool which takes
a number of inputs both internally and
externally
and contains over 14 000
component items it produces a risk score
for each of those items and each of the
suppliers that
produces those for us and then
obviously we on that basis are able to
better
prioritize our risk mitigation
activities
and here you see on the slide two or
three examples
so we have for example as a result of
this work
uh implemented dual sourcing for some of
our key reagent components
we've increased raw material safety
stock from a
from a risk-based based understanding of
where that would be most beneficial
and for
for our more complex and high risk
components we
strive to use primary producers which
increases quality
and stability in our supply chain
so in addition to the sourcing risk
finder tool
we also use a 24 7
continuous incident monitoring solution
that's provided by resilience 360.
and this provides
end-to-end visually visualization and
real-time alerts
regarding potential incidents that may
disrupt our supply chain so throughout
the kovic 1919 pandemic for example we
have received
continuous updates about threats to our
both um suppliers ability to manufacture
but also
threats to our logistic partners in
shipping material to us
um this has been a continuous and
an ongoing uh input from resilience 360.
so um this tool also provides some
incident um advice when it comes to
natural and man-made events such as
earthquakes
strikes for example at airports or any
regulatory changes
now i'm going to say a couple more words
about the uh the sourcing risk finder
tool
and give you some detail on that in a
couple of slides
um so this tool has been
developed in-house over the last five or
six years
it analyzes over 20 supply risk
attributes and i'll take you through
what some of those are
in a little while but we have
many many most of the components that we
source
are in this tool and the reason is that
we just
think that taking a data-driven approach
to understanding what
supply risks one of the highest supply
risks and how we should
best mitigate them is
a worthy objective so
the sourcing risk finder i said it takes
it uses
more than 20 risk-based attributes and
here are some of them
so we look at suppliers financial health
we look at various attributes related to
quality the supplier is
residing in a geo geographical risk zone
and this could be a political risk but
also
[Music]
more perhaps more obvious geographical
risks such as if a supply is located in
an earthquake zone for example
we do a business continuity management
survey on a subset of our high risk
suppliers in each of our factories
and that is also a factor in the
sourcing risk finder score
and that produces some supply chains of
the visibility as well
and then we look at uh perhaps the usual
candidates from an item perspective
on time delivery how long it takes a
supplier to produce and supply to us
the transfer lead time is one of our
highest rated
uh attributes in the sourcing risk
finder and the transfer lead time is our
estimate
of how long it would take to transfer to
a new supplier
if we had to we also look at
how much safety stock we have both
in-house and our suppliers whether an
item is
single or sourced or has multiple
sources
and for certain of our chemical
suppliers the
criticality that is to say what effect
the raw material has
on the performance of the finished goods
and then
lastly we we take a view on whether we
have identified
or implemented second sources
and so when we've collected all that
data we use this equation
to produce a sourcing risk index for
each part
and after that the sum of the the sum of
the part
sourcing risk index provides us with a
sourcing risk index for each of the
suppliers
so we divided the sourcing risk index
calculation into two areas
the impact and the probability
and on the left hand side you can see
the impact calculation
that is transfer lead time minus the
safety stock
multiplied by the revenue so as an
example
you could say that if you have a
transfer lead time that is it will take
you
three months as an example to transfer
from one supplier to another
if you had to but a safety stock of two
months
then in the event that you have
disruption in your supply chain
you in theory will be standing still
unable to produce
for one month and we multiply that by uh
the revenue that we receive
associated with that raw material to
produce the calculation as to the impact
to our business
and everything else of the attributes
that i showed on the last slide
is included in our um the section on the
probability
and the attributes have different
ratings according to
how important we think they are so
that's how we calculate the sourcing
risk index
and on the next slide i'm going to
explain
business continuity management survey
that we undertake
uh as i said with a subsection of our
high risk suppliers
okay so what we do with this survey well
first of all we should i should say that
we
we take a different approach depending
on whether the supplier is a
distributor excuse me or a manufacturer
and we interrogate our suppliers as to
how they manage their supply chains
and what approaches they take when it
comes to business continue continuity
management
so as i said we focus on the high-risk
suppliers
we look at whether the supplier has
calculated a recovery time for a major
incident
whether it's done business impact
analysis or risk analysis of
uh of its key operations whether a
supplier has second sources for its
critical raw materials the level of
safety stock and whether there are
alternative
manufacturing sites so in
this way we hope to gain a an
understanding of our suppliers and to a
certain extent our sub suppliers
when it comes to how they manage risk
okay so when it comes to measures that
we take
to mitigate mitigate supply risks in our
genomics business just want to run
through a couple of scenarios and a
couple of examples
so when it comes to genomics and
diagnostic solutions
in 2019 we undertook a very thorough
supply risk analysis
which um analyzed hundreds of raw
materials and
we looked at over 5000 risk attributes
in total
and we looked at the finished goods that
we manufacture ranging from ceramic
beads to dna amplification kits
so um that project took six to nine
months
and what the result was we were able to
identify
our highest risk raw materials we
developed a multi-year
risk mitigation program and we have in
place
a cross-functional team with clear
action plans
and we meet on a regular basis to ensure
that we
are driving the rigor uh as regards to
the implementation of these risk
mitigation
actions
at the same time during our what in our
whitman business um
we did a similar exercise but this was
based on
uh site workout so this took a much
much more focus on our manufacturing
operations so
each step of our manufacturing processes
from the the delivery of raw materials
through to uh all the resources and the
equipment that were used
were were analyzed and uh to gain a
thorough understanding of the level of
risk and
the potential impact from potential
disruption
so what the team did there thereafter
was
create a comprehensive risk mitigation
plan
and this looked at the qualification of
additional raw materials suppliers
additional training and cross-training
of current staff recruitment of new
staff where needed
um and then there was al we've also put
in place a security of supply leader
who leads these initiatives uh on an
ongoing basis
um so this provided us with uh you know
a better footing when it comes to
managing increases in demand in uh
during the recent pandemic
so on the next slide i want to just
quickly talk about our risk mitigation
toolkit so there are nine
titles in our risk mitigation toolkit
that range from
uh implementing second sources um
managing our inventory both internally
and externally
in different areas of financial and
contractual support
but what i wanted to do on this slide
was just describe our approach to
second sources so we have five levels of
second sourcing
or dual sourcing the first level is uh
is market screening and that's simply
that we've identified potential
alternative suppliers
level two is a supplier evaluation where
sourcing look at the supplier to see
that they're
feasible uh in terms of meeting our
standards and our requirements
level three is material evaluation
conducted by
r d which is a document
analysis of the feasibility of the
materials that
would be supplied by a potential
supplier in level 4 we've done
full r d testing and
that bench scale to validate the raw
material
delivery and performance and in level
five we've fully implemented
the second source and the reason we have
different levels is because our aim
is to reduce the transfer lead time that
is reduce the risk
and reduce the time it will take us to
implement the second source
but at the same time minimize the change
control burden
as far as our customers are concerned
so when it comes to trying to position
ourselves for success in uncertain times
when the code of 19 pandemic started to
impact our business
some of the what some of the risk
mitigation plans were already underway
so we had already reviewed the article
data stored in our erp system to ensure
it was accurate we had the
correct lead times and inventory
values and so on and so forth we started
a program to look at short-term
risk mitigation initiatives and this was
focused very much on
raising raw material inventory and
including vendor managed
inventory and we'd also started a
project to increase the number of
multiple sources
and multiple manufacturing options with
the same source
that we had for our high risk raw
materials
and in this in addition to that we
continued with our open communication
and having a clear
change notification process with both
suppliers
and customers we continue uh with our
fairly uh rigorous auto supply auditing
program but we had a review of the
buying strategy
and we continue to be very rigorous when
it comes to the testing and
very verification of incoming incoming
goods
so we have um continue continue
continue to conduct regular risk reviews
and these are conducted primarily by the
sourcing team
and um when we saw demand changing as a
result of the
the kovic 19 pandemic
the regularity with which these were
conducted was
increased dramatically so we try and get
ahead of
problems and avoid supply issues and
then of course we continue to review
our strict quality and supply agreements
and
review these on on a regular basis okay
so um in terms of where we stood
when um when the coronavirus pandemic
started to affect our business as far as
magnetic beads were concerned
you know our supplier risk management
program was underway but
very very far from complete because we'd
only done the analysis in 2019
but we looked at raw material both
internally and
externally and that gave us a healthy
starting point where we'd already
taken some steps to to increase that
we have close relationships with some of
our key suppliers
and they were really instrumental in
helping us
lower lead times and receive deliveries
of material
much quicker than would normally be the
case just to support
our very high and short-term
or urgent demand i should say
so we're very grateful to have
great support from our suppliers and
extreme flexibility but we've also taken
uh at the back end of 2019
we've executed on um implementing
uh a strategic review of our strategic
logistics partners
and so we would reduce the number of
logistics partners that we had
dramatically and this was implemented
actually january 2020
so we've been very grateful and pleased
with the collaboration we've had for our
logistics partners and they have enabled
us not only to receive material
from far away suppliers but also keep
deliveries flowing
to our customers so because of this we
were able to triple
our magnetic beam manufacturing output
in just a few months during 2020.
when it comes to membranes um we looked
at increasing working patterns
moving to 24.5 production with the
which increased production capability by
40 and we have
the capability to expand that further
moving to 24 7.
i think i've already mentioned that we
recruited extra personnel
providing more flexibility in the
workforce
and we moved to daily prioritization
meetings to make sure that the in-demand
products were being
manufactured on time and in the correct
quantities to support customer
customer demand we now have weekly
reviews of capacity
to ensure that demand is not um
the capacity can meet the the demand
that is required
and in addition to that so the last
point is that we've implemented
direct shipments from a centralized
warehouse to reduce
delivery times to our customers
so just finally on on on this point in
terms of the ongoing learnings from
these unprecedented events we found that
you know we were in fairly good shape
because
not all of our initiatives were complete
before the pandemic but we had put some
foundations in
in place we need to further improve the
quality and integrity of the data in our
erp system to make sure that we are
we can rely on that and use the the
system as it was intended
and we are continuing a comprehensive
review of raw material inventory
and we need to finalize that strategy to
further protect the business in times of
crisis
we have ongoing work which we we will
continue
when it comes to developing multiple
sources for the highest risk items
and as i said at the start really
security of supply
is a key strategic pillar for the
business
and we have a multiple multi-year
program of continuous improvement
in place so welcome and we hope to
continue to have this top of mind
continue to have it as a priority in the
business and
the intent would be for us to get better
and better
now when it comes to what customers can
do to secure a supply
there's a few points that i'd just like
to draw out really
so first and foremost we depend on our
customers forecast and this really helps
us
plan tactical and strategic capacity
and enables us to be in a better
position to meet
your demand secondly uh
the issuing of purchase orders firm
purchase orders to support demand
um and cover that demand is also a
crucial factor
when it comes to um the systems
and reagents choice we would very much
encourage
um consideration of the impact of closed
systems so for obvious reasons
the user the use of open systems does
facilitate
security of supply because for
consumables
uh consumable reagents uh a customer can
choose from a number of vendors
if they have to if supply is constrained
and then when it comes to designing
components we strongly advise
customers to take a a hard look at the
security of supply measures that those
vendors are taking
and it's also important to work with
supplier with suppliers that have strong
change change control notification
process is in place
and this needs to be replicated at
n minus one and then minus two levels of
supply to ensure
that uh consistency of supply can be
maintained
uh it's important to have a robust
supply audit process in place
as part of keeping our way of keeping
control over supply
and it's important despite the fact that
there are change control
burden options it's important to keep an
open mind about the possibilities
of dual supply options
[Music]
so when it comes to the future in terms
of security of supply
we see a few things at play first of all
the digital um environment is going to
be a key enabler
in this space okay so you know there are
developments in the pipeline
um and they're really potentially going
to transform the way
supply chain logistics uh supply chain
transparency
and supply risk management management is
handled and we're looking into these
with that with a number of vendors
um in particular looking at the use of
digital documents
the use of big data machine learning or
augmented intelligence to support our
decision making when we have
so many components and so many
attributes of play
and then of course
sophistication in the way that the large
data sets are handled
is really needed uh in the context of
interdependent supply chains so there'll
be a need from uh
across the industry through for
increased
transparency which will enable greater
uh accuracy and capacity planning
but also when it comes to uh inventory
holding
and simply being able to focus on uh
prioritizing the
mitigation of the most uh the highest
risks
okay so uh in terms of uh
availability and quality of data um
you know that's going to be a key um a
key enabler
so um manufacturers will be able to
anticipate changes they will be able to
proactively adopt
adapt i should say operations to meet
rapidly changing requirements and
customers and customers customers will
be able to
track performance and analyze
effects of different variables in
manufacturing
so in addition to that we're going to
just
spend a lot of time uh advancing our
ability
to identify high and low risk areas and
i say
using um sophisticated sophisticated
data
analysis methods to make sure that we
are prioritized
uh in the right areas focusing our risk
mitigation
efforts um on our highest priorities
and therefore hopefully continuing to be
able to
supply our customers as they would
expect so thank you very much for your
attention
thank you david for your informative
presentation we will now begin the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what investments are you making to
ensure business continuity
thanks jim um so i think it's
it's quite timely really because sativa
recently made made an announcement that
we are over the next five years going to
invest
over 500 million dollars and recruit
approximately a thousand people globally
to support uh increased capacity uh
and this will enormously help us secure
supply
in the future as the growth in the
industry
is predicted to continue
okay our next question is in what ways
are your higher management
involved in enterprise risk management
well like i said in the in the
presentation we uh
we consider that enterprise risk
management security of supply
is is part of the cultural insightiva
we're very pleased about that we get a
great support from our executive
committee
they're very interested in the different
initiatives that we're taking
to secure supply to our customers across
the business
and on a quarterly basis we have an
enterprise risk management
team meeting with our executives where
we focus on
well the current focus areas in our
security and supply program
okay our next question
can you give a recent example of your
business continuity strategy
to enable product deliveries to continue
even during unprecedented events
yeah sure so there was one great example
um involving our target factory and our
genomics
genomics business where um
the strategy that we'd set during 2019
as a result about our analysis
and the actions that we'd started to
take towards the back end of 2019 and
early in
2020 which were focused around
greater collaboration with some of our
key suppliers
increase their raw material inventory
both
internally and account suppliers
and increased number of multiple sources
in that part of our product portfolio
really enabled us to significantly
increase production
in just a few short months there was a
lot of work involved and we've got great
support from our suppliers and our
logistics
partners but in the end it worked very
well
it was a success story okay great
and we have time for just a few more
questions i want to remind
our audience that those questions we
were unable to answer today
or those that come in during the
on-demand period will be answered by the
speaker via the email address you
provided at the time of registration
our next question what are your biggest
big business continuity risks and how
have you mitigated these
so um in each of the um
the businesses are the factories we have
undertaken a business
impact analysis so for each of our major
uh manufacturing operations we
understand
uh exactly what our largest risks are
from a
business continuity management
perspective okay and those risks
do vary by sight
but one one example in one of our
factories that it was uh
through this analysis we understood that
the biggest risk was
fire so what we did was we
moved certain parts of the of our highly
floured water supply
into an area that was where it was much
safer from uh from a fire perspective
but we also have part of our
manufacturing operations
uh operating in uh nitrogen on
nitrogen controlled fire suppressant
technology so
that's one good example great
okay we have time for one more question
can you describe your supplier audit
qualification program
yes i can so um
thank you for that uh question um
so you know that our supplier audit and
a qualification program um
takes uh has sort of two key areas
really
first of all there's the the supply
selection
uh stage where we look at
what capabilities the supplier has and
make sure that they're
what they that they can do what we need
from a feasibility perspective
and then we would categorize the
suppliers by undertaking the risk
assessment
um and uh there are four
uh categories to our to our suppliers
and depending on these um
depends on on how often or under what
circumstances
we all get our suppliers so type one
would be a critical supplier
which are offers significant significant
risk
we have type two which is uh we
categorized as an important supplier
offers major risk
type three 3 an important supply with
minor risk
and type 4 is a supply with negligible
risk
and depending on how a supplier is
categorized
we take a risk-based approach to
whether and how we audit them so we
order our high-risk suppliers on our on
a rolling
risk a rolling basis uh but
from a with a risk-based approach to the
frequency and then some of our lower
risk
suppliers we conduct desk audits or
paper audits
so we take a risk-based approach but we
stay
uh we stay in touch with um most of our
high risk and
supplies of critical or important raw
materials
all right thank you again david do you
have any final comments for
our audience no i just would like to
thank
you for being my host today and uh
also thank you to everyone who
joined us for this uh for this
discussion and i hope
in some way it was at least a little bit
useful so uh
very much appreciated your participation
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration we would
like to once again thank david raw for
his time today
and for his important research we would
also like to thank labrutz
and our sponsor saitiba for underwriting
today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand lab
roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay that's
all for now until next time
goodbye